all right check out this story from the  telegraph oil cartel joins forces with  Russia to cut supplies congratulations  ladies and gentlemen because of the war  in Ukraine a gentle gentleman yes  because of the war in Ukraine that we  are involved in  OPEC Saudi Arabia are joining with  Russia cutting production cranking up  prices so that Russia can keep selling  at a premium rate to China and then sell  it back to us so we are getting screwed  and funding this war your costs are  going to go up your standard of living  is going to go down and it's because Joe  Biden is a corrupt piece of trash who  keeps funneling our money to Ukraine why  do we why should I care about Ukraine  because because Vladimir Putin's  charging too much for natural gas into  Europe well too bad you build your  pipeline like they did the Baltic pipe  fine blowing up someone else's pipeline  expanding your military Alliance all of  this was pushing towards War